Andy, how are you?
I'm good.
I wanna bring up something
here at the top of the show
because Andy Richter sits
by my side every night
and I've grown very fond of you Andy,
in the last two...
Are you firing me?
(Conan chuckles)
(audience laughing)
No.
Oh, okay.
Not at all.
Not at all Andy.
Why are you so paranoid?
I don't know.
No I have,
I've become very fond of
you over the three seasons
we've been doing this show,
and I've gotten to know
Andy better and better.
But actually a couple of
weeks ago, I said to Andy,
'You know, I really wanna know
the Andy before I knew him.'
I wanted to go and explore
the roots of Andy Richter,
the humble beginnings.
And Andy said, 'Well,
if you wanna do that,
I should take you Conan to my
old neighborhood in Chicago.'
Right.
And show you around.
And we did.
And we did that,
Just that.
and we brought a camera crew.
And I gave you sort of
it's the Andy Richter tour of Chicago.
It's not in any books.
That's right.
This is a different look
at the city of Chicago.
Right.
All Andy Richter.
Its within about a three block radius.
Okay.
And...
Well, this is exciting stuff actually.
And we're gonna show
the whole world tonight,
your beginnings.
Where you come from and
Andy Richter, Chicago.
Great.
So ladies and gentlemen lets take a look
at Andy's and Mike tour
around his old neighborhoods in Chicago.
Enjoy.
(classical music)
(audience laughing)
[Mike] This is great.
[Andy] Yeah, It's cold.
Yeah, this was a good
idea though, to come here.
I mean, and sit in Wrigley
field in the dead of winter.
(audience laughs)
Nothing funny about it?
No.
(classical music)
This is the intersection of
Lincoln Irving park and Damon.
Okay.
It is sort of the heart
of the neighborhood
that I used to live in.
And there's no better place to start
than the Lincoln restaurant.
Wow!
It's sort of like my home away from home.
Wait a minute.
This is a--
Oh my God.
I love Chicago.
(laughs)
[Andy] Here we go.
Thank you.
That looks terrific.
That's the veal cutlet Parmesan?
Yep.
There we go.
Omelette and a skillet.
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Well, here we are this is Alvin Glick.
Cool.
I used to live here.
This is pretty much where you spent two
or three consecutive
years of your life, right?
Pretty much.
Listen and we like a couple of beers
(bartender) sure what would you like?
What kind of beer do you want first?
Something German but we
brought our own glasses.
Yeah, can you fill it and these actually?
Sure, I can do that.
I hope these people have a urinal.
There we go.
(upbeat music)
Andy, what's that thing on your head?
It's an inflatable bears helmet.
Please take it off.
(classical music)
(audience laughing)
(singing in foreign language)
(mumbles)
What's this song?
That's hard to translate into English
it's about hazel nut is dark brown
Hazel nut is what?
Its a dark brown.
Hazel nut is dark brown?
And you should be the same color.
(Mike mumbles)
♪ Hazel nut is dark brown. ♪
♪ And you should be the same color. ♪
(singing in foreign language)
(laughing)
(cloud singing)
Go Andy.
♪ If I was the king of world ♪
♪ I tell you what I do ♪
♪ (mumbles) ♪
(audience applauds)
Andy what bar are we at now?
We are at Marie's Riptide lounge.
Now we should point out the
holiday decorations here
are like no other place,
can you describe what we have there
behind the bar for us, Marie?
Well it's something I decided to do
many years old is going
out for 34 years now,
every Christmas I put this up.
(Conan) Ooh, spooky.
(Andy) Yeah, it's kind of a...
by the blue lights there.
(Conan)It's a little frightening
and beautiful at the same time.
it makes you see the patrons
it makes everything white.
It makes everything white.
Yeah, glow.
It also shows up the plaque on your teeth.
(laughs)
The first time Andy
Richter walked in the door,
did you say to yourself,
that kid is destined for greatness?
I thought about it
I wasn't too sure at the time
and I'm not too sure now.
(laughs)
Still not sure
And the red has a Santa clause,
Do you really have to go?
And Santa Clause takes one, look at her,
and he said, 'ho ho ho, I got to go
my rangers are out in the snow.'
So she stands up and
she drops the negligee
and she says, 'Oh Santa Clause,
do you really have to go?'
Well he takes one look at her and he says,
'Hey hey hey I better stay,
I will never make it up
to Chimney this way.'
(laughs)
Can I use that, is that alright?
Ooh you can have it.
All right I can have it.
(classical music)
Well I wish you all a
merry, merry Christmas.
(audience applauds).
We learnt a great deal I think.
Yeah we sure did.
(clapping)
And we also... we learnt a great deal.
Now ladies and gentlemen,
we also point out that.
that was just setting the table actually
for what happened?
We actually had decided to...
tell them what we did in a nutshell.
Well we went to check out and see who
was living in my old apartment.
Right, We went to check that out.
Yeah, and some interesting
things happened.
And you'll see that actually
on tomorrow night show.
There was just too much
Chicago for one show.
Yeah.
What? you don't have TVs.
(laughs)
I was gonna,
obviously don't use them
for this program that's all.
All right.
(chuckles)
Anyway ladies and Gentlemen watch for that
and also our thanks to the city of Chicago
in the 85 bars that helped
us out with that piece.
(laughs)
We're going to take a break folks,
when we come back, Greg
Kinnear is gonna be with us
so stick around.
(shouts)